朱老師今天要拿一隻大雞腿
勝率甚至更高
幾乎你死黨有死黨
你都會成功
你碰到圓弧體
就請你要好好把握了
那個*****
元弧就完成了
這些特性如果你都先看到了
就可以準備做元弧體了
上漲的幅度54%
過濾很好了
這個噴上去就厲害了
厲害了
快一倍了
元弧多深你就漲多少
像海溝一樣
那就會什麼好怕的
對不對
你不可能賠大錢
好
鍋老師我烤烤牛
假設我們今天有個便當
雞腿便當好了
然後還有很多種還不錯的配菜
還有白飯嘛
那你會怎麼樣吃這個便當
裡面這些菜的順序
第一個就吃雞腿
當然要知道雞腿好不好吃
那是主菜
已經是你喜歡的雞腿便當
基本上會吃那個最下飯的菜
比如說有三個蔬菜
蔬菜 對
或者是比較鹹的鹹蛋糙什麼的這樣子
因為要先開個胃
喔 對
胃開了後面才比較容易吃的下
所以我們教學其實也是這樣子
對 先學續見近
先讓大家吃得下
對 然後先進門
沒錯 最後才給你一個大雞腿
對不對 對
用心量苦
就跟今天的主題有關係
喔 真的喔
今天這個也很像雞腿
哈哈哈
因為我們之前已經給了開胃菜
我們今天要講雞腿
對 然後教大家繼續抄底
好
今天的理財達人秀標古再見等讓你就等囉
因為理財達人秀從11月2號開始
已經變成天天上電視了
所以大家會問說怎麼朱老師單獨的教學
變得比較少
沒有 我們還是有抽出時間來做
而且今天剛剛我們在前面講了
我們不是常常教大家抄底嗎
前面教你了什麼 N字底對不對
然後還有頭尖底對不對
不好意思喔 這兩個是開胃菜喔
讓你下飯的
等到你覺得這個飯好好吃喔
朱老師今天要拿來一隻大雞腿
但綠甚至比N字底還有頭肩底更高欸
所以我就想老師啊 你真的是
好久成功的欸 沒錯
很會掉人家胃口 要越吃越好啊
越吃越好 大家才會一直來對不對
好 我們先來驗證一下
老師教我們超底有沒有超成功喔
我們上一集講N字底嘛
上上一集講N字底
然後有給觀眾朋友出兩個
就是考試題對不對 作業
第一檔是這個2428的心情
當時他快要成型了
所以請大家鎖股
看有沒有形成N字底往上
第二題是
三五二七這個宏觀店
也是請大家觀察
然後結果好多人有買
不是我們推薦的喔
是請大家自己判斷
你覺得有成型的話再去進場喔
後續如何 老師我們來解密
對 我們看一下
各位不要急
要學東西本來就要慢慢消化
慢慢消化
你上了一集這一集要多看幾遍
然後去把它消化
然後你因為你有時間你去驗證嘛
否則的話你一下子一直學一堆
那個股票也沒出來
好 我們上次講的N字底
我們上次講的時候位置在這個地方
對
所以我有講因為這裡有一個強力反彈
看可不可以做出第二個角
所以第一個就是你一定要等到那個位置出來
因為沒有百分之百嘛
換句話講如果沒有出N字體
它一直疊一直疊就沒有了嘛
你也不要進場
我們在做技術分析的時候
最重要就是要確認
你要把那個位置確認你才出手
那沒有確認你不要出手
那這樣子你的成功率就會很高了
好那我們在這跟紅K確認了
他已經上來了
把昨天前天下跌的都已經過高了
那這時候你就看到這邊一個低點
這個是第二個低點
那這個叫做N字底的這個四單點
我們都有講
這個地方你可以先買一點
買一點反彈的高點現在是不是過了
那這裡就可以全部買了
N字底我們也有講目標價
所以你也可以說我去守到目標價
所以你從這長到這
從這長到這真的到了
長了33%
33%獲利很好了
我們常講說
我們就算上次講
這個時間可能差不多快一個月了
你一個月賺30%
很厲害
夠了吧
而且重點在老師有強調
你要等第二隻腳
這個型態確認才能試單
你才開始試單
然後型態確認你在進場
至少你到現在是一個獲利的狀態
我們不是特地推薦他
他只是行太快成型的
請各位觀眾自己想辦法去確認
你確認到了就是你賺到
而且學到
而且大家學的目的也是這樣
你學就是希望你自己能會做
自己又可以賺錢
所以才最開心
所以今天才公布真正回去走學
再來還有一檔叫大家說股的
我們還追蹤了一檔叫做紅罐店
紅罐店也是這邊反彈
那這邊是第二支叫
這個叫四單
還沒有成型
這個型態沒有成型
那現在他還在打底
所以這支股票
基本上還沒有失敗
他還在做底部
那你們可以再鎖
我們也學過一個叫
頭肩底的型態
那現在你看像不像了
這邊疊這邊上漲
左邊盤整 右邊盤整
所以你把右邊的盤整等到他突破
他就完成了
不過它這個右肩的盤整就是比較久
時間長一點
對 時間長了些
但是我們都講
我們很多股票在追蹤
你可以鎖五六檔
像剛才這個先出來你就先賺
賺了它現在也差不多了
這一隻可能就要快出來
老師還給陳次感
大家輪流吃嘛 對不對
那隻雞腿吃完了就吃這一隻
太飽了 太飽了
OK 所以股票永遠都有機會
大家只要有耐心的
根據你學的去等這個機會
所以宏萬店他其實沒有失敗
沒有失敗
市單的人其實也還沒有賠錢
沒有賠錢
你市單還沒有賠錢
基本上還賺錢
所以有進去追蹤的人繼續追蹤他
對 繼續追蹤
按照他以後發動我們再來做
好不好
那今天我們有新的課程囉
我們已經教了N字底
也讓大家知道很厲害囉
我們N字底有90%會到目標
勝率啦
勝率的意思就是說你會成功
成功的意思就是不會停水
10次有9次應該不會遇到停水
其實你做股票能夠成功就很好了嘛 對不對
那我們講的投間底有83%
那今天這個有95%
95%
也就是說幾乎你10檔有10檔
你都會成功
有的時候會超過目標喔
第一個他這個勝率很高
而且這個型態的上漲的幅度最54%
可以漲到平均漲幅54%
所以有的7成有的8成
少的話也有3成4成
所以你平均有5成
經常大概2成一定可以抓到的
所以這個是一個很好的型態
為什麼一開始不講這個
因為你不一定都遇到這個
你如果遇到這個做這個
你遇到這個做這個
那現在你又多了一個機會
你碰到圓弧底就請你要好好把握了
所以我們今天給大家介紹圓弧底
它是勝率很高
上漲幅度也很高
那我們做股票本來就要找這種股票
是最容易成功
所以今天我們要來
好好的把雞腿來吃下去
尤其是前面兩個學得很好的同學
趕快來學第三種
反正你越懂得越多
你的機會就越多
為什麼會有圓弧底
好 那圓弧底是怎麼形成的
圓弧底它一定是有一個狀態
第一個它多空交戰
也就是說剛開始的時候空方比較強
所以它慢慢疊
但它又沒有強很多
如果強很多就像前面N字底
就刷下去了對不對
所以它是慢慢疊的
骨架慢慢的走低
走低到底負了不疊了
它就看起來就有點橫的在那個地方
然後多方的力道慢慢的大了
多方比空方大
但又不是很大
所以它又慢慢爬
所以左邊慢慢疊
右邊慢慢爬
就會爬出一個這種像圓弧的樣子
其實也就是晚了
一個晚行
對
好
所以多空交戰一樣嘛對不對
但是空方力道一開始比較高
然後後來還要經過一個橫向的整理期
對
不像我們那個N字
可能就是這樣上去了
就直接上去
對 然後再慢慢總高
所以就是一個圓弧
也就是多空力道的變化不大
對 不是很激烈的變化
所以下面你也看不到大量
它有點像小火慢燉
所以它的成交量也是一個碗
左右大 下面小
下面在慢燉 再盤整整理
然後再慢慢增壓
對 所以這是一個觀察的一個特點
可能拿實力來看比較清楚
對 我們一看圖就知道了
所以如果你去找圓弧底
你不要希望底下有大量
不要希望底下大量
是用一種燉
這是小火慢燉
所以它才會慢慢疊
它不會急疊
那這邊漲也不會急的漲
所以它因為量出來的很小
所以慢慢的漲
那這邊疊下來
這邊漲上來
這個看起來就像一個圓弧
圓弧底
就像一個圓弧
這個就是圓弧底
那圓弧底
我們這邊跳空 用跳空的過高了
哦 跳空過高就很強囉
那後來漲幅33%
漲到高點有33%
這個股票就驗證
朱老師常講的
性技術分析要像性神一樣
沒錯 沒錯
因為這一檔在基本面上面
我們曾經分析過
他曾經有出過一些狀況嗎
沒錯
但是技術現行高速你可以見
可以做
那就是相信現行
也就是你按技術分析
按技術分析出
跌破5G你就出
所以你就也沒有什麼風險
那第二個我在這裡強調
等一下我們會講新法了
為什麼園湖底在這邊
很多人都不會買
其實大部分人不會買
為什麼
那是因為你去跟下面股價比
你覺得很高了
對 如果以他的低檔來說
已經漲一段囉
因為他爬爬爬爬
你30塊 40塊 50
爬到快50塊了
然後挑戰他的前波的高低
你今天的收盤
各位看47塊
所以大部分人都不會買
覺得貴了 我沒有買到30塊
沒錯 但是今天的課上完了 你要買
那第二個各位看
當天確認都是長紅
對 一定要確認一根長紅可以放
長紅就股價更高了
所以更不會買
更不會買 都已經漲那麼多了
做到這個型態的人很少
所以這也是為什麼我們最後才拿出來
對 對 對
因為它要克服人性上的弱點
對 這有一點人性的弱點
因為每次學生都說
老師這個地方長那麼高了
可以買嗎
我說你買啊
對不對
因為他勝率很高
也就是說你長不到這個50%
不是你長不到目標價
你也有二三十%的獲利
但是老師
我們現在看到是一個圓弧了
這個圓弧不是什麼隨便圓弧都可以
那當然
要確定這個圓弧
長的是圓弧底
沒錯沒錯
所以我們基本上
來確認一下喔
有三個步驟
一個圓弧完成沒有那麼快
對
它慢跌慢長
這個時間要燉了很久
那找到空頭下跌的底部
右邊 因為它到低檔了
就不跌了嘛
這時候你去看你的左邊
左邊是慢慢跌的
但右邊不一定
右邊有時候就飆起來了
就晚有點歪就對了
所以你慢慢的要在右邊
也是一樣 要慢慢長
大概長到一半你大概就知道
這個有點像圓弧了
OK 所以它就是慢慢跌
也慢慢長 慢慢長
長到右邊的1分之1
你大概就可以開始鎖骨
猜測可能是
做圓弧底了
那周線也看到
因為你這個時間很長
好所以我們不要不只看日線
還可以抓出周線
周線也會抓到圓弧底
它一樣的
如果你抓到了也可以去算
也可以去做周的這個形態
那第三個右弧上漲
超過左弧的
確實我剛剛講右邊1分之1
你就可以把左邊那個高點畫一條壓力線
那個壓力線叫做緊線
那個緊線突破圓弧就完成了
就是我們要準備它了
所以這邊有提醒一件事
圓弧底形成的時間是比較長的
可能要兩個月以上
再來有一個很重要的
就是右弧的上漲要超過左弧的二分之一
我們才能鎖骨
然後我們再把壓力線畫出來
突破壓力才升級
就是我們要記
那你如果早點準備
表示你已經看懂了
那看懂了
所以你那個突破你就敢買了
就可以再突破點
馬上買進來
因為你早就準備好了
對不對 有塊肉來了
你早就已經準備好了
只要他確認
所以換句話說
圓弧底是一個很容易
預先準備等在那裡的
沒錯
所以大概情形是這樣
好 塗畫出來囉
慢慢慢慢疊
然後下面就在這邊
就不疊了
震盪整理
然後這邊慢慢漲 他開始漲到這你就要準備囉
漲到1分之1
這邊1分之1對過來
因為這個圓弧已經完成2分之2了嘛
你這個碗已經很像了
那你就把左邊的高點畫一條線
畫一條線出來喔
然後就等這個紅K了
紅K突破
有就有沒有就不要動
沒有紅K突破不要碰他
為什麼很簡單我剛剛講過
大家為什麼不敢買
因為你在這裡已經到高檔了
可是高檔也是預壓
你還沒有過啊 所以你不能買
可是過了呢 為什麼可以買
那叫型態
型態已經成形了
一開始講第一個型態就跟大家講了
對不對
你做型態跟做趨勢這是兩回事
我們現在做的是型態
是
型態的確認所以我進場了
如果做趨勢這邊不能進場
因為我們講趨勢是回後買上漲
怎麼會買到高檔來了
而且這個也不見得會呈現那種頭頭高
對不對 不一定喔
不一定 原虎底有時候沒有底底高
所以我們在這個地方就準備
那成交量大概也是這樣
成交量在底部的時候也是很小的
再慢慢放大
這些特性如果你都先看到了
你大概就可以準備做原虎底了
這樣子 OK
好 所以我們也用實力再讓大家看一下
好 我們來看一個實力
好 實力來了
原物底盤的時間很長很長
這個是周限
用周限來看的剛剛有提醒大家
這個2012的4月到2013的4月盤了一連
可是你看到你就賺一連
我很沒有耐性耶
你先做別的嘛
我一直看你先吃別的雞腿
而且等等這個碗啊
那個碗有點開變盤子啦老師
這是比較淺啊
可是它還是超過目標啦
這個噴上去就厲害了
厲害了 這個快一倍了
對
OK吧
所以你先去吃別的
我先吃別的
對
這隻雞腿長得比較慢
等著這一隻大雞腿來的時候
你再啃進去
長成超大雞腿
你一啃進去就不得了
對
好 那這個也是一樣
各位看這邊有亮
這邊有亮
中間這邊是沒有亮的
對
在打底的時候沒有亮
好
所以我們如果有看到
周線的圓弧體更好
所以老師你剛剛有提到
保原蝴蝶可能至少要兩個月
兩個月以上
那你看過比較平均
大概要多長會形成
因為像這個就一年了
對 因為你這看周限
你看日線就不會那麼長
日線大概就兩三個月
可是日線的漲幅
會不會沒有像周限那麼驚人
我在這裡講
這是周限
其實你在日線怎麼會在這做
你周限這裡已經是多頭了
你日線已經在做了
只是你日線已經
日線做了兩個月 三個月
然後你會發現 周獻也是
那你就繼續做
先做短再做長嗎
你從下面就開始做了
下面這邊各位看周獻
是不是頭頭高底底高均線四線多排
你這你已經做一個月的多頭了
等你一個月做到這一週
這一週結束了
你回去看周獻
周獻是圓弧確認
所以朱老師會建議
我們先從日線確定圓弧底
然後先進去做一波
然後等到覺得長到自己毛毛的
然後我們再來看周獻
發現周獻也還是元虎底
周獻也是元虎底 表示還要找
但元虎底會騙人
會 元虎底會失敗嘛
我們講形態有的時候不一定會成功
95%的勝率 但是還是會有做失敗的形態
那這邊給大家建立一個觀念
就是我剛剛講的要確認
什麼叫確認 做多一定要紅K
才確認
我們說盤整突破一定要紅的 不能黑的
黑的就沒有確認
所以這個確認K線非常重要
那我們今天又看到一個例子
是不是一個圓弧很像
這個沒問題了
雖然有一點不夠圓
但是這個幅度很大
那我現在走到這跟紅K就準備了
突破就要買囉
就是這樣橫向我們畫一個極限
我已經畫一條線了
結果當天突破是黑的
所以沒有突破
第二天突破也是黑的
所以你也不能進
雖然他看起來突破 但是是黑K棒
不可以進
就不行 絕對不行
突破一定要紅K棒
大家要比記記起來
因為我們在講K線講過
黑K代表今天有賣壓
今天賣壓代表明天還會跌
所以你今天幹嘛進去
明天還有低點嘛
黑K代表賣方力道比較強嘛
比較強
所以尤其這是長黑
所以明天還會跌
因此這個後面你就等不到了
因為他一直跌嘛
你沒有突破這根線嘛
所以你就不要進場
所以主導師幫我們歸納一下
整個圓弧底確認的三個心法
有個心法
為成功率或利率都很高的形態
對不對
聽起來這個非常的棒
然後出現三分之二圓弧
你就鎖骨囉
但是你一定要等形態確認
確認才進場
就剛剛講的突破壓力線之後
紅K棒
我們再進場
所以不要因為它這個勝率很高
你就先進
大家都想買低一點
因為你沒有確認就不一定了
要確認這個勝率就很高
勝率是型態確認後才有勝率
圓弧體塊完成就等於高檔
已經接近右弧的壓力
剛剛很快的壓力
等確認才能進場
所以這個型態不能先進場
一定要確認
我們前面兩個型態是可以先進場
所以有個試單
試單價
這個沒有
這個不能試單
好不是單
原虎底突破確認股價已經過高
可以等回測上漲再進場也可以
也就是說你原虎底
我剛講很多人心理壓力
這個太高了
沒關係
如果下次有回測你就可以買
因為
你要回測到那個壓力線上嗎
不用
只要有回測符合多頭
而且你回測之後你就多頭了
頭頭高低低高了
你就可以做了
那就是另外了
所以主要是這個沒有試單的點
沒有試單點
所以進場點要非常確認
因為不是單
沒錯
一進場就進場了
所以不能先買
我再三張
不要猜
因為剛才看失敗的那個就一直貼
對
你先買你就很容易預壓不過
預壓不過你就容易停損
你只要做停損
好
那圓弧底我們大概就是
兩個進場的位置
好
第一個就是你確認
你這邊確認
紅K我要記得
可以使你把要過左邊剛才的高點
你畫的壓力線
第二個就是你沒有進
那就還有一個回後買的
你回檔以後買
這時候不一樣了
因為你這個地方上漲
你頭頭高了嗎
沒錯
現在回檔就是底底高
所以這邊可以買
你就等下次回檔後再買
所以這裡有兩個位置可以進去
但老師這邊如果他回檔後
他跌破了這條壓力線
沒有影響
下面這個有個低點
只要這個低點不要破
那我們其實做這裡是在做多頭的確認
這個地方是多頭確認
而且因為你是原弧底
我們都講右邊是不是慢慢上漲
然後我們等一下看圖
你仔細的看
右邊的上漲都在月線上
他已經在月線上
所以他已經多頭走勢了
這兩個地方各位可以去參考
買經典喔
我們來看一下 再不買就上去囉
這是周線喔
剛才我們看的周線
所以這邊當然就是我們
突破左湖高點的買點
如果你是做周線跟日線一樣
你就守五軍嘛
就賣到最高點
周線我們也是守五周的軍線
就很簡單
那如果說我們在日線操作
那你就在日線守
守五日軍線
對 五日軍線
那因為這是周線 均線已經做好了
你可以做長線
做長線你在日線就守二十均
守月線 也可以守得很漂亮
那我們來出個考題
因為我覺得我好像都聽懂
每次都這樣 每次跟妳聊完以後
想我都聽懂了
妳每次都學得很快
好 這個是
這個看起來應該像圓弧
跌下去又長上來
好 那這個型態確認要買在什麼地方
買在什麼地方 好
我們可能要先
老師為什麼有畫這個
好像想要干擾我
不知道 我覺得是被騙了
沒有 所以我要畫出這個高點對不對
我哪有騙你 我沒有騙你啊
我等一下解釋就說
這邊是高點嘛對不對
可能畫的不是很直
所以應該在買在這一根
我先講為什麼要畫這一根
這一個點不能跌破
它不能跌破嗎
所以這一根黑K是空頭
你坐空在這裡
你在你做空是賺錢的啊
對
他一直跌啊
對不對
所以各位知道
這是空頭的這個做空的位置
好
做空的位置
所以這根不是亂畫的
好
我想說你在干擾我
因為做空以後下面變成多了
你看這根紅K上來
這根紅K上來
這根紅K就多頭了
對
這根紅K是多頭
看那沒有
這個高點過了
這個就開始多了
它就變多了
可是我今天是要做圓弧體
所以你可以在這裡先做多
做到壓力叫高點
壓力有沒有過不知道
過了就做圓弧
所以老師我這樣畫有沒有錯
來來來
從這個高點
這邊的高點畫過去
這邊的高點在這
其實也很好看
這邊的高點就在這條線
這邊嘛 這邊有一條線
對
所以差不多是這個位置
昭華畫過去
因為昭華街沒有帶齒
所以差不多這一根突破是沒有做的對不對
我不知道 等一下就會
等一下才會接小答案
今天不接小答案 好殘忍喔
又會在哪裡在榮耀班接小答案喔
等一下再接小答案 好壞心喔
不會啊 對不對
總之我做完功課了
要我就這邊買
反正我看到後面了我有賺
有賺都是對的
好 對不對
黑貓紅貓
沒關係 我們在榮耀班來揭曉
但是現在呢
要來講什麼叫做
算目標價
我們前面N字底與頭前底都有標
那算目標價
原屋底也可以算嗎
當然 當然
形態就是有目標價
好不好
那你為什麼敢再買
因為我有個目標價
我有一個地方可以賺
那這個目標價非常簡單
你左邊不是有個高點嗎
這個高點拉過來叫壓力線
所以當你一突破
就是左邊這個高點
減掉最低點
減到最低點
對 這個價差
從這個突破點加上去
就是你的目標
那我當然希望他
這個晚功越深越好
當然越深越大
找得像海溝一樣
哇
那一個優型的話就更好
那當然你的目標價就會比較高
可是你目標價高
就可能不會一次就到
不會說一直長就到
因為你太遠了
那中間可能就會有個回檔
那如果你有個回檔的機會
離目標還沒有到
還有一段距離
是
你還可以加碼
喔
對啊 因為我已經算好了嘛
假設我目標價有10塊
那我漲了3塊就回檔了
回檔以後再漲 那我就可以再漲
它就會容易到...
因為你已經經過回測
那到目標價機率就非常高
所以這個目標價的算法其實也很簡單
就圓弧多深 你就漲多少
可是這個達成率也是像
剛老師講的那麼高嗎
9成5啊 所以最好是坐在突破點
因為你成功的距離非常的高
才能整碗端距離
但是你一定要突破
再講突破成功率才高
但是也有可能會需要遇到停損
停損或者是回檔或者是回測
或者是我已經長得不標較
我要拜拜囉
我們來看一下
我們就實際來看
這叫周線
也是用周線來看
周線左邊是不是這個高點一直跌
那跌到這邊右邊又上來
在最低點11塊7後面就打底了
那你如果要從下面
因為你上面還沒有發生
你在下面看到多你已經開始做了
開始做
做到這個禮拜大家看長紅大亮
長紅喔
不是黑的
你就可以知道我的圓弧底完成了
完成了 那你剛剛進場囉
完成了這個地方的高點是23塊
這你是11塊7毛
你減了以後加上去
哇這支股票會漲到34塊
有教大家嘛
對 這個高點減掉底部
就是你的目標價囉
目標價就是這個嘛
這個就是算出來34塊3
那34塊3你大概賺了11塊
23塊賺11塊
也很棒 要5成
4成到5成
對不對 也有4、5成的
當然要做啦
可是這裡有一個回測
這裡有一個回來
那回來之後你買
然後你把停損守好
最後到了
到了就回檔了
那這是週馬
回後買上漲
那是後面
後面再做趨勢了
好不好
好 那如果你是周限看到
就算周限的目標價
如果你是日限看到
你就算日限的目標價
這樣OK
好 所以這個目標價算
但是老師
我這邊停
另一後面漲一大段
再漲了再做
怎麼做法
它沒有破無日均
我就繼續做了
這個破伍的啦 黑的破了嘛
我以後買上漲啊
這是多頭進場的位置
不是形態 不要放棄他就對了
當然啦 因為他是多頭
你進場你看第二週 第三週 第四週
多漲啊 又漲了三個禮拜
那就有什麼好怕的 對不對
你不可能賠大錢
那我們再看一個囉
再看一個喔
這個很明顯吧
你看得懂嗎
那前面的高點你突破了
突破把它算一算
大概有6塊
大概剛好6塊
6塊的獲利
會漲到28塊6
這是三層
所以你看慢慢的
所以我在這邊也有講
因為這是周限
所以你食物進去了
是不是有停損
所以沒有停損
然後上漲
這邊跌破了5均
你在這裡你就賣
賣了以後他還是一個多頭你就買
買了又跌破你就賣
所以你不會賠嘛
對不對
但是要遵守機率
那這是空頭囉
所以你就不要管
到這個地方他才到目標家
周限有時候走很久
挺辛苦的
所以我們在日線做
我們超盤都在日線超盤
好不好
捐獲的我一直跟大家講
第一個就是他是很好的形態
第二個就是突破確認要大量紅K
那第三個如果你確認了要敢買
否則這個機會就沒有了
老師我跟你講
下禮拜來的時候
我就會告訴你
我做了一檔圓弧底
真的
我覺得今天這一集我特別有興趣
然後我沒有一集不被你念的
都有盲點
那你做到了賺錢
那我就可以吃雞腿便當
沒問題
我就買十隻雞腿鋪在桌上好不好
好 那今天我們教的圓弧底
之後覺得真的是很容易學起來
而且勝率高 漲幅也高的喔
那當然不要忘記了
我們理財當然就有榮耀班
我非常謝謝非常多的朋友
因為我們之前有100塊的精英班對不對
但是說真的100塊
很難支撐那麼好的節目的營運啦
所以後來我們就請大家
通通加入榮耀班喔
那榮耀班有任何的問題
都可以提出我們都會回答你
那剛剛我們家的園戶底學起來了沒
我們在裡面有出一個考題喔
我也不知道我做對了沒有
因為朱老師說他要等
後面榮耀班才要公布答案
再加上
圓弧底還是會有例外
會跟你開玩笑會失敗
那怎麼樣能夠避免這個失敗
我們一樣在榮耀班裡面講
那非常謝謝朱老師超級佛心
講了三種超底的方式
大家學好了沒
N字底學好了沒
頭尖底還有今天的圓弧底
這邊是一個滿滿學習的殿堂
希望大家都能夠學會超底
在古海裡面賺到你最大的波段
朱老師說要爆好爆滿
那我們今天也不要苦
我們在線的理財單秀就到這邊了
我們下次再見 掰掰